we're about 20 minutes into the film
this is our first time
in the courtroom it's opening arguments
are the people ready to make opening
arguments
we are your honor i don't have my lawyer
here it's not your turn to speak
my trial's begun without my lawyer
please sit
mr schultz we have 12 principal
characters
a lot of story to start setting up we've
got to show bobby's conflicts
with the judge we have to understand why
consular
and wineglass their hands are tied they
can't help bobby or they'll hurt bobby
we have to see tom's pain with the
shenanigans that's
going on with abby and we are
hearing for the first time what these
guys are being charged with and why
they would tell you that one group
excuse me
yes sir i'd like to clarify something
for the jurors
there are two huffmans in this courtroom
the defendant
abby hoffman and myself judge julius
hoffman
thank you sir i didn't want there to be
confusion on the matter
man i don't think there's much chance
they're going to mix us up
abby understood the power of humor and
comedy to
expose the ills of society and humble
the powerful
the aim of this was for it to be
entertaining enough
that the american public would watch it
that defendant hoffman and i
are not related father no
from the moment aaron called action to
when he called cut
in pretty much every single take these
actors sasha eddie and yaya
were unbelievable they gave me such a
wealth of material to interpret and play
with and the coverage allows me
to pick and choose where to emphasize
how to emphasize
so in a scene like this it's also the
reaction shots that really make a huge
difference
when sasha is wisecracking with the
judge or interrupting him
tom it's his worst nightmare as we'll
find out he's
approaching it quite differently their
strategies are different so it's
important to see it getting under
him the simmering that's going on
because it's developing over time he's
reacting to everything abby says and
does
again the defendants would tell you that
these are three distinct
groups but they all excuse me yours
may i speak no sir he just said my name
you're a defendant in this case you're
likely to hear your name
i have a right to counsel and his honor
knows that
don't tell the court what it does and
does not know
be seated you know i say it almost every
time i'm talking about the movie it
really felt like theater
and when i say theater i mean to say
that it felt not like i was on the stage
but it felt real
and authentic and it felt like something
that i wanted to do and i was excited to
do over and over again you know i try to
look at everything as a love story
and a good story will attempt to take
that idea of that person away from our
character who is
in love and so for myself you know bobby
was a character who was in love
with freedom excuse me have we
identified the
other defendants for the record uh mr
um weiner winer mr froins and
mr dillinger dellinger your honor what's
going on here
uh your honor you're referring to the
defendant dellinger darrendrew
um it's dellinger sir note the
prosecution
was referring to the defendant derringer
not delanger is dellinger your honor can
we straighten this
out sure dillinger was a bank robber
derringer is a gun he's david dellinger
and the judge and i
are not related one of the joyful things
about watching this for me
is it pretty much was our first day of
shooting in the courtroom itself
and it was at the time which frank
langella playing the judge had
asked aaron for the sake of performance
he could be kept away from the rest of
the actors because he wanted to be an
antagonist
and we kind of loved that when we heard
it and it really did sort of set up this
antagonism
and after about three days he saw us all
kind of chatting between takes and
having a bit too much fun
and decided that actually he was going
to give that up and come and talk to us
but looking back on that scene
that's what it reminds me of for that
first few days you weren't allowed to go
and say hi to frank
forgive me have you concluded your
opening statement
yes sir my lawyer charles gary is in a
hospital in oakland having undergone
gallbladder sir mr consular
you are sitting right next to the man
just represent him
it's the same case the fact that there's
a lawyer near
mr seal does not satisfy the
requirements of due process i have
i'm right emotion was made for
postponement due to mr gary's medical
condition
i was there your honor denied that
motion therefore mr seal is here
without legal representation i don't
care for your
general tone mr consular i
in no disrespect to the court i'm trying
to be clear
that i can't muddy mr seal's grounds for
appeal
by appearing to speak as his lawyer i
don't ask you to compromise
mr seal's position sir but i will not
permit him to address the jury when his
perfectly competent lawyer
is still fourth time he's not bobby's
lawyer
you're uh mr rubin
yes sir don't ever do that again
i wanted people to feel like every time
we came back to the courtroom
that oh this is going to be a place it's
kind of a circus
this is going to be a place where we're
going to have fun
and at that point you can punch him
the audience i mean in the stomach and
speaking frankly the u.s attorney wanted
a negro defendant to scare the jury i
was thrown in
to make the group look scarier i came to
chicago i made a speech just to see
chicken pot pie went to the airport and
i flew back to oakland
and that's why they call it the chicago
get your hands off me
it was a master class of actors and we
would often have a couple of hundred
people
who are extras and at the end of the
first
take you would often get a round of
applause
so much of tom early on in the film is
listening
and is trying to take in everything
that's going on
with great strength of opinion himself
but not really being able to articulate
it and that moment when he goes into the
room and slams that door
is a release of that we have to make a
decision right now a decision
i just assumed we'd already made four
months ago when trial prep began
are we using this trial to defend
ourselves against very serious charges
that could land us in prison for 10
years
or are we using it to say a pointless
[ __ ] you to the establishment [ __ ] you
that is what i was afraid i don't know
if you were saying
[ __ ] your ass i was also confused if we
leave here without saying anything about
why we came
in the first place it'll be
heartbreaking as the scene unfolded i
found a rhythm
following the performances that really
let us be on each character at the right
moment and then work our way in from
wider shots to closer shots and that
scene
we worked on as much as any scene
perhaps and we went back later to give
it more subtlety and nuance because it's
tom and abby who we know at the end of
the movie are going to have
a major blow up and that is where it
really starts and we had a lot of fun
with it abby you cannot talk back to the
judge and jerry
did you get a haircut just for court
i did you did you got a haircut for the
judge that is
i can't that is that is so
foreign to me so is soap zing now let me
explain
something it took you two less than five
minutes to make us look
exactly like what schulz is trying to
make us look like really it's
deep frustration at the approach of the
trial
uh you know for abby as he says in that
scene it was political
and that the result of the trial was
already predetermined
um rather than something to get through
in order for these people
to uh refocus on their calls and i think
that is how
how tom's looks like real revolution
cultural revolution
why did you come here i got an
invitation from a grand jury
last summer why did you come to the
convention to end the war
guys before you tether yourselves to
this man just know the very last thing
he wants
is for the word end that comment that
tom says to abby
hurts him so deeply because abby is
ready to risk his life and ready to die
for the cause to fight injustice what in
the name of hell was that
evidently not you stood up and spoke for
bobby i made it very clear that i'm not
his lawyer i like to sit in on these
meetings
you can i think i will anyway fred
bobby's life is at stake and you guys
are playing to the crowd
thank you shut up white guy sitting in a
furnished room eating sandwiches while
bob is sitting in a holding cell
i'm dealing with a character that was
bombed you know that didn't have the
same
freedoms uh he was a black man at that
time
in a system that does not and that did
not uh
allow him uh the same type of liberties
as it did
the rest of the defendant so for myself
that was my way into it you know
and the story provided me opportunities
to to speak out but uh but also at the
same time it was also important to show
the ways that that he was silenced
you got to try to convince him
i can't we'll try i have
well keep trying all right we're back
let's go jerry abby unless you ask the
direct question
i want you to keep your mouth shut in
that room this is a political trial
what this is a political trial looking
at that
uh now i'm just reminded
about how phenomenal the script is
i mean that's what every actor dreams of
is it it's just as somebody who tries to
write myself
it's mind-blowing the fact that each of
those characters
is completely defined that it's funny
that
it's insightful that the rhythm the fact
that it's so
entertaining i mean i haven't seen that
for months
and it's aaron brilliant
so the masters are spreading the word
that we got to keep moving go left on
roosevelt and back in the park right
before we even get to the park and this
is the first
this is the first violence in the film
before we even get there
you can create energy with language
so we kind of start coming at you from
every direction with
all kinds of narrators
[Applause]
abby doing his stand up just came up
with that but
you know when [ __ ] happens when you
don't give protesters a place to go
how would you characterize the mood of
the crowd different people on the
witness stand cutting them
together a thousand strangers do you
have an objection
yes sir on what grounds on those grounds
so you start to get a lot of different
voices
mr wood gasket the crowd was looking for
a fight
a lot of different locations we were at
a great advantage because we got to
shoot this
in grant park uh in chicago and on
michigan avenue in chicago where the
riots
actually took place well
the guns there are no permits for this
demonstration you're ordered to leave
the park immediately put down your guns
[ __ ]
fight like [ __ ] men my plan was
i was gonna get a few wide shots
utilizing the smoke from the tear gas
we were going to see people in the
foreground through the tear gas we were
going to get a sense that there are many
more people
back there don't make me sad put the
flag down
[Music]
and those were the ingredients which
allen
then in the editing room uh weave those
things
together and we created that ride right
now
yeah someone from the crowd shouts a guy
somewhere in the crowd shout
someone in the crowd shouted
[Applause]
the street name for chloroacetone for
gnome is tear gas
and it's a [ __ ] blow torch your lungs
your skin your eyes riot clubs
they're made out of the same wood they
use for baseball bats
so i had this material and that gave me
the ability to
break it up more and follow the script
with the dialogue so that the
riot scenes were just in the right
measure we didn't want to linger too
long we wanted to have them
uh reveal and inform what was being told
and have their own little moments of
[Applause]
energy
tear gas canister landing of someone's
eyes right before
a club went into them blood
and the other big player in uh
in that riot sequence is daniel
pemberton a composer and there was just
there's something about the
music that daniel wrote throughout but
particularly
for the two riot sequences and then for
the final q that makes it different it
makes it special
all right hey you're okay here
just got to hold this over your face
okay hold this over your face
i can take you to the first aid station
okay you're all right
i got you we have to go okay i'm gonna
get you out of here
don't move jerry then get those guys